mais déjà battu mon dire la vérité ouais
vionnet la vérité et franchement je suis
un peu d'accord avec le mec à vélo et je
suis moi quand je suis en avait long et
qu'un mec qui ce mec tu dois faire un
écart et qu'elle sait quoi tu ne dis
c'est une tannée parce que tu si tu dois
t'en tübingen vous jouez pas au
justicier si aucun vous appauvrissez
quand même mais mine de rien c'est vrai
que c'est une tannée
quand tu es à belhout est une voiture
que tu dois passer après tu t'es un mec
là ça peut ça voilà et il prend des
risques
non je veux dire la vérité à lui le pot
il faut qu'ils faut qu'il fasse
attention parce qu'à un moment là lui il
est gentil mais il va tomber sur un mec
il va lui prendre ses papiers va lui
faire bouffer choqué voilà vous par
exemple quoi comme vous par exemple mais
ça arrive tu veux qu'on en parle des
vélos quoi oui c'est s'aider des
statistiques de paris plus d'un vélo sur
deux ne s'arrêtent pas au feu à
autorisation il n'y a pas de moteur
alors il s'en tard à moi morrison tu
passes
c'est ce que le voilà aussi j'avoue que
les bleus se croient tout perdre à japy
tanguay et te traite de tous les noms et
respecte rien céder le témoin dessus et
c'est vrai que moi aussi je passe
valache pas d'avoir été aussi dangereux
de l'arrêter il ya une semaine la casse
que j'étais passé en vélo voilà au feu
rouge et les positions étaient très
sympas ils m'ont dit monsieur nous nord
n'a pas envie de vous perdre
oui en tunisie on sait comment ça se
passe et oublie pas serré que ça mais
l'impact l'an dernier tu ne perds pas de
point en vélo dont tu ne perd pas de
points c'était pas de permis donc les
gens n'ont rien à [ __ ] ils prennent
juste un élément c'est dangereux comme
mais qu'ils arrêtent de donner des
leçons des vélos qui me remonte par
l'effet rumeurs mais yann ryanair veolia
cargo je vous le dis je ne regrette donc
le meilleur vous allez prendre une seule
dans la gueule en tunisie justement en
fait on en a pas en a pas encore des
pistes c'est jacques pollet pour les
vélos par contre ceux qui aiment faire
du vélo fait s'ils vont dans des forêts
ou dans des parcs
c'est rare qu'on est des rendez vous
professionnels dans les suspects se paie
alors demain alors pour le conseil
d'administration se donnent rendez vous
devant le 4e arbres je serai
rendez vous boulogne c'est celle où va
incarner bois de boulogne
e
voilà